[Applause]
a trip to hospital after a painful few
days with cheers from the crowd and
smiles from the couple The Prince and
Princess of Wales back to work in
Liverpool meeting Health teams
and we're doing it in sort of a brand
new way and mental health mentors this
is what they want to focus on but it's
hard resetting the Royal narrative have
you had a chance to read your brother's
book at all have you had a chance to
read your brother's book at all your boy
highness
Prince Harry's book dominating headlines
for days and although sales are soaring
polls show his popularity is plummeting
well he's brought on himself as far as
I'm concerned he blamed the British
press and all he's been doing is go to
the Press I mean most people have family
drivers who just keep it to yourselves
don't yeah you think I'm Plastering it
everywhere I just wonder what you think
about you know William and Kate getting
on with the job really I think you know
what they've done kept silent just
carried on as normal is the right thing
to do so you don't think they should
have commented no definitely not no let
him get on with it
also getting on with it the king in
Scotland on his first duties of the year
do they all get on he asks if only
families were as easy to manage inside
and upbeat the unveils of plaque
a lighter moment at the end of a week
he'd probably rather forget
despite the deafening noise around Harry
The Royals are still staying silent
trying to carry on regardless of his
Revelations his claims and of course his
criticisms
they've been braced for a difficult
start to the year but now it's back to
business
the royal family hoping their actions
will speak louder than Harry's words
Laura bundock Sky News Liverpool